Continuing in Riyadh al-Salihin
and tonight we'd to discuss a
narration
which has been transmitted to us by way
of Aisha
the Prophet Sallallahu alayhi wasallam's
wife and virgin bride
the most beloved of his wives to him
also the youngest of his wives.
and
Aisha
is not just
some silly child that
grew up
amongst the companions
and them.
She wasn't just some passive presence in
the Prophet Sallallahu alayhi wasallam's
life.
Ibn Hajar al-Hajar
states in al-Fath
Fath al-Bari
he says that Aisha is responsible for
transmitting
1/4
of all the rulings of Islam.
I don't think that we can truly
understand the magnitude of that
statement. One single person
who when the Prophet Sallallahu alayhi
wasallam passed away, she was 18 years
old when he passed away.
So when when he died, she was 18.
Imagine an 18-year-old today. I mean,
there's no comparison.
This
female, this wife of the prophet
Sallallahu alaihi wasallam is
responsible for transmitting
1/4 of all of the rulings of Islam. And
that is
an incredible feat on its own.
But, being that it comes from Ibn Hajar
rahimahullah, he's referred to as
al-hafiz.
He was known for his expansive
studies of the Quran and Sunnah
to the point that out of 1,500
years of scholars in the in the
millions,
when you say al-hafiz, it is Ibn Hajar.
This man
tells us that Aisha is responsible
for 1/4 of all of the ahkam. And not
only that, but she is one of the seven
most
memorized
of all the companions of the prophet
Sallallahu alaihi wasallam.
So, when we say, "Who are the the
companions that narrate the most
narrations?" There seven of them. These
seven are referred to as the seven major
narrators of Hadith.
And Aisha radiAllahu anha is one of
them. One of them is Abu Hurairah.
This is to give you an example as to how
much
what we know today hinges on what Aisha
radiAllahu anha observed, memorized,
learned, and then
continued to narrate and transmit to
us and teach to her generation so
thoroughly that a fourth of all rulings
of Islam hinge on her testimony and 1/7
or a little bit less of all
narrations of the prophet Sallallahu
Alaihi Wasallam come from the narration
of Aisha.
In Sahih Muslim, Aisha radiyallahu anha
narrated
that the messenger of Allah Sallallahu
Alaihi Wasallam said one day,
"Man ahabb liqa Allah
ahabb Allah liqa'ahu.
Wa man kariha liqa Allah
kariha Allah liqa'ahu."
He said,
"Whoever
longs for
the meeting of Allah, whoever wishes to
meet Allah, Allah wishes for his meeting
in turn,
in response.
And whoever
dislikes
the notion of meeting Allah, Allah in
turn dislikes the notion of meeting
them."
Now,
this is a statement that
many people would just hear from the
prophet Sallallahu Alaihi Wasallam,
memorize it,
and continue to transmit it. But Aisha
radiyallahu anha, she inquires, she asks
because immediately the idea comes into
a person's mind that
when is the only time any one of us will
be able to meet Allah? What has to
happen for us to meet Allah?
You have to die.
So, if I dislike dying, if I go out of
my way way to avoid death, does that
mean that I am avoiding Allah's meeting?
Does that mean that I do not want to
meet Allah because I do not necessarily
want to die?
This is a connection that
Aisha made immediately. Most people
would not make this connection
immediately.
And so Aisha
she immediately upon hearing this says,
She said,
"Oh messenger of Allah." He says,
"Whoever desires Allah's meeting, Allah
desires to meet him. Whoever
does not desire, whoever dislikes the
notion of meeting Allah, Allah in turn
dislikes the notion of meeting him." So
she says, "Is this the same as disliking
death?
Because there's not one of us except
that he or she naturally flees from
death. We dislike it."
Every one of us, I I believe.
I can speak for myself. If an angel were
to descend right now and say,
"You are going to die tonight. Pack your
bags." I wouldn't get up and dance about
that. I'd be pretty bummed out. Why? Not
because I don't want to meet Allah. It's
because of the baggage that I'm bringing
with me to this meeting.
Right? This is the problem. The problem
isn't the believer doesn't want to meet
Allah. The problem isn't that the person
is necessarily afraid of death or its
process, which in itself is a very
grueling process. However, the problem
is all of the baggage you bring with you
to that meeting. That presents a
problem.
And so Aisha
says,
"Oh messenger of Allah, is that the same
as disliking death because all of us
dislike the notion of death?
He says, "Laisa kadhaliki."
Aw qala laisa kadhalika.
[Silence]
And so,
she said
she asked her question, the Prophet
Sallallahu alaihi wasallam responds by
saying, "That's not what is intended.
Rather, what's intended
is that the believer,
when he is at the brink of death,
when his soul is being prepared by the
angels of death to be extracted from his
body, when the angel of death is there
looming over him, retrieving his soul
from
amongst his flesh and bones,
he will be given glad tidings of the
mercy of Allah
and the pleasure of Allah
and the paradise of Allah.
And so he will then be happy and long
for the meeting of Allah.
However, and then in turn Allah will
love his meeting.
However, the disbeliever
when he is in that position
he will be told of the punishment of
Allah and the impending anger of Allah
that he is about to enter into.
And he will in turn hate the notion of
meeting Allah and Allah will in turn
hate the notion of meeting him.
And this is something which is specific
to this ummah.
Of all the nations
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala tells us that
this nation
is specific in that when the angels of
death come to collect and harvest the
person's soul
they will show this person his place in
paradise or in the hellfire.
And so as the person is laying there
or whatever the situation is, even if
their death is what they say sudden and
painless. You know the painless death?
Was he in pain when he died? No, he
didn't have any pain. You weren't there,
I wasn't there.
time is very relative.
A moment
in our time as we are experiencing it
now
could be a thousand moments to the
person who is in the process of dying.
But what we do know
is that the prophet sallallahu alayhi
wasallam tells us that every one of us
will go through a very lengthy process
in dying.
He tells us in the narration of
when a person is about to be
to have his soul retrieved
the angels of death
will surround this person as far as his
eye can see.
That is all he can see is the angels
around him.
And they will prepare this person's soul
for retrieval.
And one of the angels will stand there
with a
a
shroud
either of musk or a shroud of fire.
Then when it is the precise moment that
that person is to
die.
The angel of death
will
come
and will retrieve this soul.
And will immediately place this soul
into the shroud of musk or the shroud of
fire.
Now this process the prophet
tells us
that when this angel descends and when
this angel comes
he will say to the believer
As Allah mentions in Surat al-Fajr
in so many words
all righteous soul
come out of that body
and come into the pleasure of your Lord
and the bounty of your Lord
and the paradise of your Lord.
And when the believer hears this, the
soul will become tranquil
and will willingly
come out of the body, this flesh and
bone.
And the prophet Sallallahu alayhi
wasallam tells us that the believer's
soul will come out the last drops
of water come out of a vase.
It's not tight.
Just drips right out, right naturally.
Nothing is more natural in the world.
And conversely
the disbeliever
when he is told by the angel of death,
"Come out
Come out and come into
the
anger of your Lord, the damnation of
your Lord, the displeasure of your Lord,
the judgment of your Lord."
The soul will become afraid and disperse
into the extremities of the body.
Upon which
the angel of death
will then rip this soul from the body
just like
cotton or wool that is wet that gets
stuck in a thorn bush is ripped out.
This is the description that the prophet
gives us, Sallallahu alayhi wasallam.
And so at this moment
the believer will see his place of
paradise, the disbeliever will see his
place
of damnation,
and at that critical moment the person
will either love the meeting of Allah or
hate it.
And Allah will in turn love or hate this
person's meeting.
And this is what is meant by the
statement that the prophet gives us
here. This is an adage. This is a
proverb, right? This is something to
live by. These are words to live by.
You know how we have adages? Better safe
than sorry.
Better to have and not need than to need
and not have,
right?
We have adages that we live by. They
help us to make decisions.
Here's an adage.
Whoever loves Allah Whoever desires
Allah's meeting, Allah will desire his
meeting.
And whoever hates to meet Allah, Allah
hates to meet him as well.
That is because at that critical moment
when we see people dying suddenly, that
is only us seeing that.
This person goes through the same
process of death
that every other person goes through.
To us it seems a moment. To them
it may seem like
a week, a month. We don't know.
We're only going to know when we're on
that in that position, and every one of
us is going to be in that position.
And
[Arabic recitation]
which we will end with.
And that is
the following.
This idea of having a painless death
or having an agonizing death, a painful
or a painless death,
that is only up until the point
when a person
time has come when they will be when
they will die.
When the angels appear,
pain or painless is not dictated by the
violence or lack thereof that a person
dies under.
It is dictated by that person's position
with Allah.
If they are righteous person, painless.
And if they are to the contrary,
all of the pain which you could never
imagine.
This is the reality of death that we
cannot see.
You can't see what's really going on
with the person as he's dying.
That's something that is the most
intimate thing between a person and his
creator is when he is dying. When he is
born, when he is dying, and when he is
[Arabic recitation]
What are you going
I saw you were
trying to keep Who's yourself?
Assalam alaykum.